jetzt ist die demokratie gefordert
thüringen muss eine antwort finden
das land mit der niedrigsten
arbeitslosigkeit in den neuen
bundesländern hat bodo ramelow als
ersten linken ministerpräsidenten
bestätigt alles so wie früher nur ohne
cdu dachte mancher wähler und entschied
sich für den kretschmann des ostens
links ist in thüringen die neue metern
noch mehr als jeder fünfte wähler
entschied sich für hacker fdp zwei
bieter besonders für die cdu
das ist nicht nur protest oder der
aufschrei von abgehängten nein der hacke
wählte wählte den flügel wählte bewusst
rechtsextrem
das ist schockierend und zeigt 30 jahre
nach dem fall der mauer eine neue
spaltung
die thüringer fdp schneidet schlechter
ab als zuletzt in sachsen und
brandenburg der zwischen
selbstüberhöhung und feigheit
schwankende blöcke hat weder den
angestrebten wahlsieg noch eine
regierungsbeteiligung erreicht wohl aber
die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz
die afg jubelt heute abend aber sie muss
entscheiden ob sie sich weiter von dem
ehemaligen geschichtslehrer aus bad
sooden-allendorf treiben lässt
erst einmal kann ramelow
geschäftsführend weiter machen auch eine
minderheitsregierung ist denkbar
für ganz neue erfurter verhältnisse
könnte jetzt mike mohring sorgen der
konservative christdemokrat könnte wagen
wozu ihm sogar kurt biedenkopf riet die
koalition mit den linken
das wird seine zeit brauchen und könnte
zur innerparteilichen zerreißprobe
werden
aber die cdu ist auch in baden
württemberg auf die grünen zugegangen
trotz tiefer greifen und eine deutliche
mehrheit der thüringer cdu wähler ist
offen für dunkel rot schwarz weimar
liegt in thüringen
doch diese demokratie ist wehrhaft und
kann antworten finden auf politischen
extremismus